so  um  players often they don't have this  appreciation that without selfless  tournament organizers so just For the  Love of the Game put together these big  events  there there wouldn't be events and they  wouldn't have their wealth  Fame  PSJA jerseys  so I think being thankful to the  organizers is really something that  should be pronounced Vegas took  instantly I don't have a lot of time  online game is apparently a drop but  it's also a flack  it's amazing how they can perfectly play  these end games with zero time and  Magnus will give a drawing because he's  such a sportsman  yeah you can pretty much that one out  anyway I think  sorry I think you could pre-move that  one out the king can't go too far from  the pond so  yeah you can't drag this one out for too  many moves  yes